Muchas gracias Chris. Y es en verdad un gran honor
tener la oportunidad de venir a este escenario por segunda vez. Estoy extremadamente agradecido.
He quedado conmovido por esta conferencia, y deseo agradecer a todos ustedes
sus amables comentarios acerca de lo que tenía que decir la otra noche.
Y digo eso sinceramente, en parte porque -- (Sollozos fingidos) -- ¡lo necesito! (Risas)
¡Pónganse en mi posición!
Volé en el avión vicepresidencial por ocho años.
¡Ahora tengo que quitarme mis zapatos o botas para subirme a un avión!
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Les diré una rápida historia para ilustrar lo que ha sido para mí.
Es una historia verdadera -- cada parte de esto es verdad.
Poco después de que Tipper y yo dejamos la -- (Sollozos fingidos) -- Casa Blanca -- (Risas) --
estábamos viajando desde nuestra casa en Nashville a una pequeña granja que tenemos
50 millas al este de Nashville --
conduciendo nosotros mismos.
Sé que suena como cualquier cosa para ustedes, pero -- (Risas) --
miré en el retrovisor y de repente simplemente me golpeó.
No había caravana de vehículos allá atrás.
¿Han escuchado del dolor del miembro fantasma? (Risas)
Éste era un Ford Taurus rentado. Era la hora de la cena,
y comenzamos a buscar un lugar para comer.
Estábamos en la I-40. Llegamos a la Salida 238, Líbano, Tennessee.
Nos alejamos de la salida, comenzamos a buscar un -- encontramos un restaurante Shoney's.
Cadena de restaurantes familiar de bajo costo, para aquellos de ustedes que no lo saben.
Entramos y nos sentamos en el área reservada, y la mesera llegó
y mostró una gran conmoción por Tipper. (Risas)
Tomó nuestra orden, y luego fuimos hacia la pareja en el área reservada junto a nosotros,
y ella bajó tanto su voz que realmente tuve que aguzar el oído para escuchar lo que estaba diciendo.
Y ella dijo "Sí, ése es el antiguo Vice Presidente Al Gore y su esposa Tipper".
Y el hombre dijo, "Ha llegado hasta aquí abajo por un largo camino, ¿no?"
Ha habido una especie de serie de epifanías.
Justo al día siguiente, continuando con una historia totalmente verdadera,
me subí a un G-5 para volar a Africa para dar un discurso en Nigeria,
en la ciudad de Lagos, sobre el tema de energía.
Y comenzé el discurso diciéndoles la historia de lo que me acababa de suceder
el día anterior en Nashville.
Y la conté bastante del mismo modo en que la acabo de compartir con ustedes.
Tipper y yo íbamos conduciendo nosotros mismos, Shoney's, cadena de restaurantes familiar de bajo costo,
lo que el hombre dijo -- ellos se rieron.
Di mi discurso, luego regresé afuera hacia el aeropuerto para volar de regreso a casa.
Me quedé dormido en el avión, hasta que durante la media noche
aterrizamos en las Islas Azores para recargar combustible.
Me desperté, abrieron la puerta, salí a tomar algo de aire fresco,
y presté atención y había un hombre corriendo a lo largo de la pista de aterrizaje.
Y estaba agitando un papel, y estaba gritando,
"¡Llamen a Washington! ¡Llamen a Washington!"
Y pensé hacia adentro, en medio de la noche, en medio del Atlántico,
¿qué en el mundo podría estar mal en Washington?
Entonces recordé que podría ser un montón de cosas.
(Risas)
Pero lo que resultó ser fue que mi personal estaba extremadamente alterado porque
uno de los servicios de teletipo en Nigeria ya había escrito una historia acerca de mi discurso.
Y ya había sido imprimida en ciudades a todo lo largo de los Estados Unidos de América.
-- fue imprimida en Monterrey, chequé. Y la historia comenzaba,
"El ex vicepresidente Al Gore anunció en Nigeria ayer,
'Mi esposa Tipper y yo hemos abierto un restaurante familiar de bajo costo, llamado Shoney's,
y lo estamos manejando nosotros mismos'".
Antes de que pudiera regresar a suelo norteamercano,
David Letterman y Jay Leno ya se habían puesto manos a la obra
-- uno de ellos me tenía en un gran sombrero blanco de chef,
Tipper estaba diciendo, "¡Una hamburguesa más, con papas!"
Tres días después, me llegó una bonita y larga carta escrita a mano de mi amigo y compañero
y colega Bill Clinton diciendo, "¡Felicidades por el nuevo restaurante, Al!"
(Risas)
Nos gusta celebrar los éxitos del uno y otro en la vida.
Iba a dar una plática acerca de ecología de la información,
pero estaba pensando que puesto que planeé hacer un hábito de por vida el venir a TED,
que tal vez podría hablar acerca de eso otro día. (Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: ¡Es un trato!
Al Gore: Quiero enfocarme sobre lo que muchos de ustedes han dicho que les gustaría que diera más detalles.
¿Qué pueden hacer ustedes acerca de la crisis climática? Quiero empezar con --
voy a mostrar unas nuevas imágenes, y voy a recapitular sólo cuatro o cinco.
Ahora, la presentación de diapositivas. Actualizo la presentación de diapositivas cada vez que la doy.
Agrego nuevas imágenes porque aprendo más acerca de ello cada vez que la doy.
Es como el mar y las playas ¿saben? Cada vez que una marea entra y sale,
encuentras algunas conchas más.
Sólo en los últimos dos días, obtuvimos los nuevos récords de temperatura en enero.
Esto es sólo para los Estados Unidos de América. Promedio histórico para
enero de 31 grados. El pasado mes fue de 39.5 grados.
Ahora, sé que querían más malas noticias acerca del medio ambiente.
-- estoy bromeando -- pero éstas son las diapositivas de recapitulación,
y luego voy a abordar nuevo material acerca de lo que ustedes pueden hacer.
Pero quería dar más detalles sobre un par de éstas.
Primero que nada, aquí es donde estamos proyectados llegar con la contribución de Estados Unidos al calentamiento global,
con el estatus quo de siempre. Eficiencia en electricidad de consumo final y consumo final de toda la energía
es la fruta que está al alcance. Eficiencia y conservación:
no es un costo, es una ganancia. El signo es erróneo.
No es negativo, es positivo. Éstas son las inversiones que se pagan sólas.
Pero también son muy efectivas en desviar nuestro camino.
Autos y camiones -- hablé sobre eso en la presentación de diapositivas,
pero quiero que lo pongan en perspectiva.
Es un objetivo de inquietud fácil y visible, y debería serlo,
pero hay más contaminación del calentamiento global que proviene de esos edificios
que de autos y camiones.
Los autos y camiones son muy significativos, y tenemos los estándares más bajos en el mundo,
y entonces deberíamos encarar eso, pero es parte del rompecabezas.
¡Otra eficiencia de transportación es tan importante como los autos y camiones!
Los renovables a los niveles actuales de eficiencia tecnológica
pueden hacer esta gran diferencia, y con lo que Vinod, y John Doerr, y otros,
muchos de ustedes aquí -- mucha gente directamente involucrada en esto
-- esta cuña va a crecer mucho más rápidamente de lo que la actual proyección la presenta.
Carbón capturado y secuestrado -- eso es lo que CCS significa
-- es probable que se convierta en la aplicación determinante
que nos posibilitará continuar utilizando combustibles fósiles en un modo que sea seguro.
Todavía no muy cerca.
OK. Ahora, ¿qué pueden hacer? Reduzcan emisiones en sus casas.
La mayoría de estos gastos también son redituables.
Aislamiento, mejor diseño, compren electricidad verde donde puedan.
Mencioné automóviles -- compren un híbrido. Usen tren ligero.
Piensen en otras de las opciones que son mucho mejores. Es importante.
Sean consumidores verdes. Tienen opciones con todo lo que compran,
entre cosas que tienen un efecto severo o un mucho menor
efecto severo sobre la crisis climática global.
Consideren esto. Tomen una decisión de vivir una vida neutral de carbón.
Aquellos de ustedes que son buenos en el desarrollo de marcas,
Me encantaría obtener su consejo y ayuda sobre
cómo decir esto en un modo que se concecte con la mayoría de la gente.
Es más fácil de lo que creen. Realmente lo es.
Muchos de nosotros aquí adentro hemos tomado esa decisión y realmente es muy fácil.
Reduzcan sus emisiones de dióxido de carbono con todo el rango de opciones que tienen
y luego compren o adquieran compensaciones para el resto que no han
reducido completamente. Y lo que significa es ampliado en climatecrisis.net.
Hay una calculadora de carbón. Participant Productions reunió,
con mi activa participación, a los líderes mundiales en escritura de software
sobre esta misteriosa ciencia del cálculo de carbón para construir una
calculadora de carbón amigable para el consumidor.
Ustedes pueden con mucha precisión calcular cuáles son sus emisiones de CO2
y entonces se les dará opciones para reducir
y para cuando la película salga en mayo, esto será actualizado a 2.0
y tendremos compras de compensaciones a través de clicks.
Después, consideren convertir su negocio a neutral en carbono. De nuevo, algunos de nosotros hemos hecho eso,
y no es tan difícil como ustedes creen. Integren soluciones climáticas en todas sus innovaciones.
Ya sea que ustedes sean de la tecnología, o del entetenimiento,
o comunidades de diseño y arquitectura.
Inviertan de manera sostenible. Majora mencionó esto.
Escuchen, si han invertido dinero con administradores que
compensan con base en la ejecución anual,
nunca se quejen de nuevo acerca de administraciones de ejecutivos reportadas trimestralmente.
Con el tiempo, la gente hace lo que se le paga por hacer. Y si ellos juzgan cuánto
se les va a pagar con el capital de ustedes que ellos han invertido,
basados en los rendimientos de corto plazo, van a obtener decisiones de corto plazo.
Mucho más que decir acerca de eso.
Conviértanse en un catalizador del cambio. Enséñenle a otros, aprendan sobre ello, hablen sobre ello.
La película sale -- la película es una versión en película de la presentación de las diapositivas que
di hace dos noches, excepto que es mucho más entretenida. Y sale en mayo.
Muchos de ustedes aquí tienen la oportunidad de asegurarse que mucha gente la vea.
Consideren enviar a alguien a Nashville. Escojan bien.
Y yo personalmente entrenaré gente para que dé esta presentación de diapositivas, con nuevos propósitos,
con algunas de las historias personales obviamente remplazadas por un enfoque genérico,
y -- no sólo son las diapositivas, es lo que significan, y es cómo ellas se eslabonan.
Y así voy a estar conduciendo un curso este verano
para un grupo de gente que está nominada por diferentes personas para venir y luego darlo
en masa, a comunidades a lo largo de todo el país,
y vamos a actualizar la presentación de diapositivas para todos ellos cada semana
para mantenerlo justo en la vanguardia.
Trabajando con Larry Lessig, será en algún momento del proceso
puesto con herramientas y derechos de autor de uso limitado,
para que la gente joven lo pueda mezclar de nuevo y hacerlo a su propio modo.
(Aplausos)
¿De dónde salió la idea de que deberías quedarte alejado de la política?
No significa que si eres un republicano voy a intentar convencerte de ser un
demócrata. Necesitamos a los republicanos también. Éste solía ser un tema bipartidista,
y sé que en este grupo realmente lo es. Háganse activos políticamente.
Hagan que nuestra democracia funcione del modo en que se supone que debe de hacerlo.
Apoyen la idea de poner un límite a las emisiones de dióxido de carbono, a la contaminación por calentamiento global,
y comercializarlo. He aquí por qué: en tanto Estados Unidos esté fuera del sistema mundial,
no es un sistema cerrado.
Una vez que se convierta en un sistema cerrado, con la participación de Estados Unidos,
entonces todos los que estén en una mesa directiva
-- ¿cuánta gente aquí sirve en una mesa directiva de una corporación?
Una vez que es un sistema cerrado, tendrán responsabilidad legal si no exhortan a su ejecutivo en jefe
a obtener el máximo ingreso de la reducción y comercialización de emisiones de carbono
que pueden ser evitadas. El mercado trabajará en resolver este problema si podemos lograr esto.
Ayuden con la campaña de persuasión masiva que comenzará esta primavera.
Tenemos que cambiar las mentes del pueblo norteamericano, porque actualmente
los políticos no tienen permiso de hacer lo que tiene que hacerse.
Y en nuestro moderno país, el rol de la lógica y la razón ya no incluye
mediar entre riqueza y poder del modo que lo hizo alguna vez.
Es ahora la repetición de comerciales televisivos cortos, estimulantes, de 30 segundos, de 28 segundos.
Tenemos que comprar muchos de esos anuncios.
Renombremos el calentamiento global, como muchos de ustedes han sugerido.
Me gusta crisis climática en vez de colapso climático,
pero de nuevo, aquellos de ustedes que son buenos en diseño de marcas, necesito su ayuda en esto.
Alguien dijo que el test que estamos encarando, un científico me indicó,
consiste en si la combinación de un pulgar oponible
con una neocorteza es una combinación viable.
Eso es realmente cierto. Lo dije la otra noche, y lo repetiré ahora: esto no es un asunto político.
De nuevo, los republicanos están aquí, esto no debería ser partidista.
Ustedes tienen más influencia que algunos de nosotros que somos demócratas.
Ésta es una oportunidad. No sólo esto, sino conectado con las ideas que están aquí
para darles más coherencia.
Nostros somos uno.
Muchas gracias, lo aprecio.
(Aplausos)